the power to manifest is in experiencing
the fullness of the present moment the
undifferentiated fullness what Jesus
called life in its fullness in one of
the translations I want you to have life
in its fullness he said and that is not
stuff he's not referring to things life
in its fullness is an inner state of
being it is to experience to know to
realize the being is within you the I am
which is consciousness itself that is
life that is the fullness of life in the
words of Jesus the fullness of life you
know yourself as Consciousness once you
know that then no future moment can
possibly be better anything that can
happen in the future isn't adding on to
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to believe myself
quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how you can reprogram your
subconscious enjoy
so if you bring together
if you have a vision in your mind of
what it is you want to achieve or create
or manifest
and you bring this Vision into this
sense of
still
fullness
that you sense now
and you bring that together that is the
most powerful creative tool the way that
it's usually expressed is Jesus
expressed it too he said when you pray
for something
believe that you already have it that's
but I think he probably used actually
slightly different words but that's how
it was written down
he's he's probably said feel that you
already have it whatever it is that you
want to have that you think is going to
be you need to you need to feel already
the feeling that you know how do you do
that
by feeling that which is beyond
the world of phenomena out of which
everything arises which is consciousness
so when you know yourself as
Consciousness that's already the
Fulfillment let's say even an
insignificant thing let's say you want
to happen uh
a nice house let's just say
if I had a nice house in the out in
nature then I would be really happy
I want to have a nice a nice house in
nature next to a little Forest and then
there's a lake there and I can walk to
the lake and then how would you feel
okay
I would feel exactly the way I'm feeling
now
[Music]
foreign
chair and then I would sit in there
every day and contemplate the ocean well
good luck
how would you feel
what would you feel I would feel the
fullness of life
okay
and you can't feel it now no why can't
you feel it now because I'm not sitting
in this deck chair
and I'm not looking at the ocean
and it's not Sunny
that's why I can't feel the foot and I
don't have a house behind me that I say
is mine so I can't feel the fullness of
life now
okay then do you think you're going to
feel it when you're finally sit in there
they say no if you can't feel it now you
can't feel it then
because you will be again dissatisfied
in your deck chair behind the house
because you will get very bored
and stung by mosquitoes
to hunt anyway should have gotten the
house higher up because
down here by the beach it's just too hot
why didn't I get a house for it higher
up because there's a mountain just
behind me would be cooler
when you sell your house
get one higher up but in the nights are
too cold you can't sit outside anymore
if you're not if you cannot feel the
fullness of Life on your bicycle
and enjoy that moment tremendously of
being on your bicycle
you will not feel the fullness of life
when you're sitting in your Rolls-Royce
or Bentley or Ferrari tester testerone
test tester Rosa
thank you
there's an overvaluing of things around
you
that I need things to be in a certain
way around me to be happy and content
that doesn't mean that you cannot change
the environment around you you can take
steps towards changing it because you
may have certain preferences that's fine
everybody has a preference is the
preference there's some spiritual
teachers who say
well I don't know I can't remember but
there are some who say I have no
preference
well
they live somewhere but not somewhere
else
so you must have a preference for being
there unless somebody Picks Them Up and
puts them somewhere
so you can you can have a preference for
living here rather than there yes this
country rather than that country
but while you're not there
you can be be in touch with the fullness
of life within yourself now
and then it's much more likely that your
external surroundings will reflect your
State of Consciousness rule number two
is practice welcoming emotions with
Rhonda Byrne getting rid of negative
emotions also negative emotions are
covering over your basic nature which is
happiness and all of their sights blame
in The Greatest Secret I explained it
all in here
um and so yeah it's your it's your basic
nature so negative emotions are covering
up your happiness so to get rid of those
emotions is really really important so
now I wanted to explain that to
everybody who doesn't know about the
welcoming process
and now let me explain the welcoming
process to you what we tend to do with
negative emotions is we tend to resist
them so don't feel good right and so we
want to push them away we don't want to
feel them we don't want to feel fear we
don't want to feel disappointment in
patience and anger and so we'll push
them away we think we're pushing them
away but in actual fact we're pushing
them down here into our body into the
subconscious mind and they act like a
pressure cooker they're causing harm to
the body but they also act like a
pressure cooker in that they need to
release some energy to so that because
they're just about to burst and so
they'll find something in the world an
emotion will find something in the world
to get angry about to release the
pressure in your body and so welcoming
is the opposite to resisting you're
pushing them away now you're not going
to do that now you're going to welcome
the negative emotion so when a negative
emotion arises basically what you're
going to do is kind of do nothing you
know really
um welcoming is just stopping us from
resisting what I do is I imagine that
that emotion is a really really good
friend of mine and I'm just allowing it
to be here I'm allowing it to be here in
the body and I just imagine that it's a
friend and I put my arms around it and
as you welcome it or allow it to be here
something absolutely incredible happens
it just dissolves it just dissolves and
in that moment you have managed to get
rid of a whole lot of that negative
emotion in your body and so that's why
this is the most incredible process
because a you will get happier and
happier B every desire you've ever
wanted will be fulfilled and say you
will have the most incredible life a
life free of fear and um and knowing who
you are and understanding the incredible
power you have in the world so just
imagine that it's you have a friend and
you're putting your arms around a friend
that is how I do it but also too
something you can do is I'll just make
sure you can see my arms what you can do
is just open your arms up like this
because opening your arms like this sort
of opens the whole chest area and that
automatically makes you stop resisting
right and you open like this and you
will feel that negative emotion dissolve
and it's the best and just do it until
it dissolves and don't be concerned
don't let any thoughts bother you about
it just do this one practice most
incredible practice in this book this
practice will take you to Lasting
happiness and um and just a life you
can't believe
understanding why it's so important I
explain in the book
how all of these things are suppressed
in our subconscious and so I think it's
great to understand more because the
more that you understand how powerful
you are and the things that you can do
to have an incredible life the better
off your life's going to be rule number
three is assess the results with Bob
Proctor when I trained to observe our
frequency and vibration and people are
not sure so if someone's listening and
watching us today how do they know what
their vibration or their frequency is
how do they diagnose that well I think
the only way to do it is by the results
you're getting
it'll tell you right makes sense see the
results do tell the truth they don't lie
Spirit manifests through its polar
opposite always we're Spiritual Beings
Spirit flows to and through us
and we'll do anything for us whatever we
ask it'll give us
and we're asking in thought
so what we want to do is take a look
what have I been thinking take a look at
your results you'll know what you're
thinking
that's how you can tell the frequency
you're on you want to start
frequencies vibration vibrations feeling
when you say I feel bad what you're
really saying is I'm not in a very good
vibration
you say I feel particularly good you're
saying I'm in a pretty good vibration
conscious awareness of vibration is
referred to as feeling
um
so I think the way to really understand
the frequency and the vibrations you're
operating on is by the results you're
getting
yeah and if you're continually having
problems in all areas of your life
you're on the wrong you're in the wrong
vibration you know very low level of
vibration
and we can change it now I teach that in
the seminars I have ways of illustrating
and everything and it's important and as
people get into it
they really like it see I think when you
hear the truth you'll know it
and
I came across I don't know it came to me
I guess I was searching for a way how to
explain that
when you hear the truth you'll know it
well
there's music in this room right now
there's music in your room you may not
hear it but we know it's here
it's being broadcast it's in the room
and we don't hear it because our ears
are not operating on the frequency the
music is being broadcast on
but if we turned on a radio the radio
picks up on that frequency speeds it up
to Zippo way up onto higher frequent and
we can hear it
well
it's the receiver on the radio I picked
it up sends it up on a higher level
where you hear it
when you hear the truth the truth
resonates with the essence of Who You
Are
and when it resonates IT sets up that
vibration it comes out on the conscious
level as knowing you just know
you just know that's right yeah when you
hear the truth you'll know I know it
that's true
well that's true when you're reading
something
when a person says something to you
you're just I know that's not true
I know that is true
it resonates with the essence so we
there is perfection our spiritual DNA is
perfect
and when we hear the truth it's like
that's the receiver and it clicks in you
know
yeah we're pretty
fascinating expressions of life you and
I and everybody else I mean
the beautiful part is like I've studied
this like a scientist probably
more serious as the time goes on
but for 60 years starting on the 21st
like this past October this is my 60th
year and I study this every day I mean
this is I'm obsessed with this
and
at one time that bothered me uh it
doesn't anymore
and so
I I just don't stop studying it and it's
so beautiful
bring that that other thing up instead
of bothering me
I think you hear things and you think
they're positives are negative I hear
Obsession I thought that was negative
somebody told me I was obsessed with
something or I thought I was obsessed
then I got a hold of Lloyd C Douglas's
book The Magnificent Obsession and I I
thought how could it be negative it was
magnificent you know yeah
so I got the dictionary out and I looked
the word up I don't know why I hadn't
done it before that
and it says an obsession is the
persistent disturbing preoccupation with
an often unreasonable idea
it's a magnificent definition also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is create from
awareness with Joe dispenza I went to
your retreat at the end of 2020 and
there's a lot of talk about 3D versus 5D
creation
and
what this sounds like to me or what
maybe I'm asking is when you get to that
point of having that knowing or feeling
something so deeply and having that
coherence
resonance in the body are you connecting
now to the simultaneous timelines in the
quantum field of that reality actually
happening that you could feel it like
so I'm asking that and I'm asking I get
and I'm saying I would get overwhelmed
with the idea of parallel timelines and
being able to have time collapse into
everything happening simultaneously so I
just want to say that it confuses my
head I can't see it clearly it doesn't
make sense to me but I trust in it so is
that kind of what's happening and I
really want to talk about creating in 5D
because I think that's where we're at
okay so I'm gonna have to unpack that a
little bit I I think this is a great
conversation okay um and for the for the
audience I think we just got to lay down
a little foundation so we don't lose
anybody right perfect so we live in a 3D
three-dimensional reality everything
that we look at an object a person
anything that's physical or material has
height and depth and width and we can
pick things up right and we can say well
that's an object and I have a body and
now that I have a body and I'm aware I'm
a Consciousness then I'm local in space
and time and and in this reality of
three-dimensional reality there's an
infinite amount of space space is
eternal space is actually accelerating
right now it's no longer expanding it's
accelerating okay so we know that space
is eternal and the way we experience
time in three-dimensional reality is we
have to go from one point of awareness
like I'm Stan sitting here and if I want
to go to my garden I put my attention on
another point of awareness that's my
other point of Consciousness now if I
want to have the experience of getting
to my garden or picking a piece of
uh fruit off my tree I have to move my
body through space and when I move from
one point of awareness to the other
point of awareness that that interval is
called time so everything in
three-dimensional reality takes time to
create you you you experience separation
I'm here and you're there and
everything's separate from me and so
our senses plug us into
three-dimensional reality think about
this if you weren't if you were lost all
your senses you weren't seeing you
weren't hearing you weren't smelling you
weren't tasting you couldn't feel with
your body you would have no experience
of three-dimensional reality and yet you
would be conscious and aware but you
would have no interaction with anything
physical or material okay that makes
sense
all right so then the way we get about
creating our future is that we say Okay
I want to have this new house I want to
have a dog I want to have a new
relationship I want to live in this
place and what the brain automatically
does based on its experience of itself
up until that point remember the brain
is a record of the past it's it's a
Memory Bank of everything you've learned
and experienced so the brain says okay
let me predict how this is going to
happen I got to take on a second job
okay I gotta start saving my beans uh I
got to make better choices
um uh I may actually uh try to figure
out a way to invest better you know
you're gonna and and your brain says
okay I'm gonna have that life
in two years if I do if I if I if I get
my behaviors to match my intentions and
I keep making the same choices I'm going
to run into that experience okay so
let's think about it the same thing
occurs there's me here Joe dispenza I'm
aware that I'm local in space and time
and then where's my future way out there
my brain is forecasting it way out in
the future based on what I've done in
the past or what I know about myself in
the past okay so now I gotta go from
this point to that point and I'm
separate
from that experience so I'm gonna spend
my entire life
waiting for that experience to happen
to take away the lack or separation from
from having it so the interval between
the thought of what I want and the
experience of having it is called time
cause and effect right so then as we
said earlier when you have the
experience you get the house you know
and you pay it off and it takes 30 years
you know you're you're too old to enjoy
it you're going to sell it anyway you
know you're everything's you know you've
it's everything's taken a lot of time
yeah and a lot of energy and it takes a
lot of time and energy to move your body
through space and time and then throw in
the hormones of stress and stress is
when you can't predict something when
you have the perception something's
going to get worse or you're going to
lose control of something in your life
you switch on that pretty primitive
system where you're going to mobilize
all your energy it turns out that those
very chemicals actually heighten the
senses rule number five is love the
present moment with Gabby Bernstein
you've talked a lot about how
you know we're living at a time when
there's a lot of competition there's a
lot of uh comparing there's a lot of you
know me versus this or competitors and
peers and all that kind of stuff and but
in this book you know and a lot of that
makes us feel like what I'm hearing you
say you're like oh I'm having fun like
I'm enjoying it but a lot of us turn to
being strict with ourselves whereas you
take an approach of saying let's be
compassionate with us tell me about that
almost Paradox because we almost feel
like okay well if I'm competing I need
to get more organized and more strict
and more whereas you're actually saying
no be more compassionate yeah one of the
biggest blocks to being a super
attractor is the comparison and the
belief that there's not enough to go
around and I actually wrote a whole
chapter in the book called there's more
than enough to go around I love that
yeah and it's for that person that's
like The Pusher or that I identified in
the book the person that's like if I
don't do it it won't happen
and everybody around me is better than
me or I'm not or I'm better than
everybody else and that separation and
that judgment that self-attack and all
the ways that we feel unworthy and so
when we start to identify the ways that
we're pushing and controlling we can
begin to unpack that and I guide the
reader in the book to unpack that
behavior and to recognize how much it's
blocking someone from from allowing and
letting what they desire to come into
their life because the real secret is to
feel good the secret is to love where
you are in the moment and not compare
yourself to where you think you should
be because once you start just being
psyched about what is more of what you
desire comes to you and I I can stand
behind that wholeheartedly and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is change your
thinking process with Louise Hay the
universe takes your thoughts and words
very literally and gives you what you
say you want always
this is another reason to keep a happy
mental atmosphere it is easier to think
in positive affirmations when you feel
good
think of it this way every thought you
think counts but don't waste your
precious thoughts
every positive thought brings good into
your life every negative thought pushes
good away it keeps it just out of your
reach how many times in your life have
you almost gotten something good and it
seemed to be just snatched away at the
last moment
if you could remember your mental
atmosphere at those times you would have
the answer too many negative thoughts
create the barrier against positive
affirmations
if you say I don't want to be sick
anymore this is not an affirmation for
good health you have to State clearly
what you do want
I accept perfect health now
I hate this car does not bring you a
wonderful new car because you are not
clear and even if you do get a new car
in a short time you will probably hate
it because this is what you've been
affirming if you want a new car then say
something like this I have a beautiful
new car that suits all my needs
some people say life sucks which is a
terrible affirmation can you imagine
what experiences that will bring you but
it isn't life that sucks it's your
thinking that sucks
that thought will help you to feel
terrible and when you feel terrible no
good can come into your life
don't waste time arguing for your
limitations poor relationships problems
illnesses poverty Etc the more you talk
about the problem the more you anchor it
in place
don't blame others for your problems
it's just another waste of time
we are all under the law of our own
Consciousness our own thoughts and only
we attract specific experiences To Us by
the way we think
when you change your thinking process
then everything in your life will also
change you will be amazed and delighted
to see how people places things and
circumstances can change
blame is just another negative
affirmation and you do not want to waste
your precious thoughts on it
instead learn to turn your negative
affirmations around into positive ones
for instance I hate my body becomes I
love and appreciate my body I never have
enough money or money flows into my life
in an abundant way I'm tired of being
sick or I allow my body to return to its
natural vibrant health
I'm too fat or I honor my body and take
good care of it nobody loves me
I radiate love and love fills my life
I'm not creative
to I'm discovering talents I did not
know I had
I'm stuck in a lousy job can become
wonderful new doors or opening for me
all the time
I'm not good enough
or I'm in the process of positive
changes and I deserve the best
this does not mean for you to be
frightened of every thought you think
because when you first begin to make the
change over and really pay attention to
your thoughts you will be horrified to
realize how negative much of your
thinking has been
so when you catch a negative thought
just think to yourself This is an old
thought I no longer choose to think that
way then find a positive thought to
substitute for it as quickly as you can
remember you want to feel good as much
as possible thoughts of bitterness
resentment blame and guilt make you feel
miserable
that is a habit you really want to
release
affirmations are solutions that will
replace whatever problem you might have
whenever you have a problem repeat over
and over all is well everything is
working out for my highest good
out of this situation only good will
come and I am safe
this simple affirmation will work
miracles in your life
I would also like to suggest that you do
not share your affirmations with others
who may pooh-poo these ideas when you
are just getting started it is best to
keep your thinking to yourself until you
have achieved your desired results
and I hear this from so many people
Gabby I'm doing it all I'm meditating
I'm praying I'm setting intentions
creating vision boards but I'm not
manifesting one reason you're not
manifesting is because you don't believe
in what you're trying to manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just trying pushing control and try to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy
and so you have to do your part to get
into the belief system of knowing that
this is indeed something you are worthy
of so how do you get into that grounded
belief system create a vision statement
a statement that claims that your desire
is on the way that you are worthy of
what it is that you desire ground
yourself in that statement focus on it
and instead of focusing on the outcome
focus on the feeling of what it is to
believe and know that you are worthy of
your desire if you're wanting to attract
a romantic partner into your life a
vision statement could sound like I
believe I'm worthy of the love that I
desire where I believe that I am ready
to receive that romantic relationship in
the perfect time and Order say that
vision statement daily for at least 40
days get yourself grounded in the belief
you have to believe it to receive it the
next reason you're not infesting
because you're trying too hard
sorry to say it but it's true the more
you push the more you control the more
you try the more you affirm the more you
vision board more than more the more the
less you receive if you're pushing and
you're controlling and you're trying to
make something happen if you are
completely out of alignment with the
universe you're not aligned with that
freedom that presence of Love The Art of
allowing rather than doing forcing
making happen
yeah we have to show up for our life but
we can't force our dreams to become a
reality so the key here is to let go so
here's your message the secret to
manifesting is to forget what you think
you need let it go how do you let it go
with this intention
thank you Universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all when
you make it about the highest good and
not about what you think you need then
the universe can truly show up for you
you can relax and allow even more than
you could imagine to enter into your
life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
wait what do you mean well what I mean
is that you're leaning into the negative
you're judging a lot you're focusing on
scary things that make you so anxious
and you just keep focusing on them and
dwelling on them you're obsessed with
worrying you love to overthink things
look I understand that behavior more
than anyone could imagine I'm a
recovering Warrior I'm a recovering
anxious person I've been there I
understand that but when we are not in
that vibration that's relaxed released
at ease present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low Vibe
energy is blocking our high Vibe
attracting power so what do you do focus
on the good stuff lean into the positive
look for Solutions rather than problems
stop yourself when you notice that
you're being judgmental or gossipy hang
out with people that make you feel good
do things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of Joy the
universe will deliver so if you're not
attracting what you desire just relax
it's all good focus on these methods
notice when you're out of alignment and
come back to this video practice one of
these methods use these tools ground
yourself back into alignment believe it
to receive it feel good and it will come
to you naturally we have the power
within us to attract what we desire when
we allow our internal condition to
reflect what we want to attract on the
outside so make that your highest
priority I want to explain something to
you that not many people really
understand I want to talk about the law
of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavier than Earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work well I use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body now I want you to
think of this for a moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the Dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here and that separates the conscious
mind from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed when you're a little baby
this is the way it was so just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm now with
paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for Generations now I'm going
to say that the Paradigm is X-Type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
Consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
X-Type thoughts therefore you're going
to be in an X-Type vibration
and that will produce X-Type results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract you see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
body's in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the Paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change our thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm and if you don't change the
Paradigm nothing happens now talking
about paradigms is another subject we'll
do that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the Paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a Y
type thought which is totally different
than the X-Type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type done the Paradigm will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the Paradigm in the thinking control the
vibration you're in and the vibration
you're in is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
Consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen
in 1961 the man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what I tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but I did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then I took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here you need to
create an environment of Excellence
Excellence most people's environments
are not excellent the people around you
the the videos that you watch the things
that are on your wall the voices that
are in your head you have these moments
that are bold that are courageous that
make you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life that you
want to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and the more intense it becomes the more
you're actually living it the faster
you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now here and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of espresso to help you but if it's
not my channel it's some other channel
one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good and
you watch it the next day and the
feeling's gone so you can't just read
the same book over and over watch the
same video over and over and over again
the key is to find a consistent source
so if you love this channel you love
this video I'm making other videos just
like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more a sense of hope
and purpose that you can do it too
you'll start to think more like him so
be careful who you pick and maybe you
don't like Elon Musk maybe you like
Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or whoever
but the more you're around that person
the more you will start to think like
them so you want to put that as part of
your daily routine that every day
because yesterday was a different day
you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you got the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
[Music]
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels that make you feel that way so
do an audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram anywhere you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this that I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting it into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so this office inspires me
this office this was all with intent the
people on the wall behind me we got
Steve Jobs apginini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be
so whether that's a mood board you put
up for yourself where there's people
that inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push a
little harder it inspires you to want to
believe in yourself and more it inspires
you to want to go off and take some kind
of action today the physical environment
matters a lot and you can control that
so think about think about your office
think about your bedroom think about
your car think about where you're
spending significant time and how much
of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work the
they're cheesy but
you've been crying I'm fighting
the belief I want people to believe in
themselves more and I'm going to work
when I see there was a green arrow show
I used to watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're out fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team uh I I don't see my team
physically that often most people work
from home I could just show up every day
in my pajamas
by putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
God is up to you but but how present
yourself for yourself not just for the
camera I'm not putting this on just for
the camera I'm putting this on because
it's what I put on this is for me
I could make a video in my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder this is how you start to create
an environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because it's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
entire life will change we had a
Thanksgiving where literally we had no
food and and we wouldn't have starved
but we weren't gonna have a Thanksgiving
dinner and uh there was a knock at the
door and that knock changed my life
because it was someone who delivered
food for us it was just a delivery man
the person who actually sent it and I
didn't acknowledge who they were and the
man said this is just a gift for you and
your family my father didn't react very
well to it at the time
um didn't want charity but a necessity
took it in and I just remember at that
time thinking to myself
why is it that my father worked so hard
because he did work he wasn't unemployed
and yet here we are with no money on
Thanksgiving not even for food and it's
just my whole life had been that way and
I just I couldn't understand why we were
living on the other side of the tracks I
lived in what I thought was a rich
Community it was actually a middle class
Community lower middle class but
everybody else we live right next the
railroad tracks quite literally and
everyone seemed like living a different
lifestyle and I couldn't understand and
my father I felt was as good as their
fathers as a person why did we have such
lack why was there such scarcity why did
they have so much abundance in us not
have any and I really didn't have the
answer until I sat in that room with Jim
Rohn and he asked a question he said you
know what does it really take to do well
financially what does it take to have
real economic abundance
and he said you must bring value to the
marketplace I'll never forget and I
thought what the hell is he talking
about value to the marketplace
and he made it very clear that we all
have value in our own Souls but that's
not what we get paid for we also don't
get paid for effort we don't get paid
for our time we get paid to find a way
to add value and the question he asked
at the time was how is it possible that
some people earn twice as much money as
you do or four times or five times or
ten times as much money in the same
amount of time
and he said the answer is because they
found a way to add more value that is
the secret to abundance do more for
others than anyone else on Earth and if
you can do that you can build a brand
you can build a company you can build a
life you can build friendships that are
Beyond Compare and so that simple little
philosophy was really simple and he went
a little deeper he was very specific he
said you know if you look at it I
remember at the time he said if you work
for McDonald's in those days he said you
make 250 an hour
I remember he said you know
somebody's working making 250 now and
they're barely surviving today working
McDonald's you make eight dollars an
hour by contrast a little inflation but
this is 1977. and he said so why do
these people make so little and somebody
that he gave the example back then of
the gentleman who was the head of Disney
and he's made 52 million dollars in the
same year
one person's making 250 an hour somebody
just makes 52 million is that how is
that possible isn't that fair isn't that
unfair
and I remember at the time in pausing
and saying well anybody can learn within
an hour how to really do the numbers and
use a cash register in fact today you
don't even know the numbers you just
push a button with a picture on it right
anybody can do that it's not being
disrespectful so there's not a lot of
added value in fact soon robotics will
probably take most of that over because
it's it's not something that expands the
human spirit it's not a complex task
that makes us expand or grow and offer
something
but he said you know the guy that
figured out how to turn Disney around
with having trouble it's worth 52
million because he's bringing joy and
happiness and love and laughter to
millions and millions of people so if
you help millions of people you're gonna
do well
in the Bible it says if you wish to
become great learn to become the servant
of many
which as Jim used to say is you know
that means there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be great but greatness comes
from serving a large number of people or
at a deep level one of the two and so
you look at it today and today the story
is the same you work at McDonald's it's
eight dollars an hour and I just got
finished writing a book where I
interviewed 50 of the most successful
Financial people on Earth that started
with nothing and you look at a guy last
year David Tepper was the highest paid
hedge fund guy he got paid 3.5 billion
dollars last year now that looks like
incredibly unjust experience you know
it's insane it's insane to think that
that man's gonna make 3.5 and someone
else is going to make 15 000 a year at
eight dollars an hour basically how how
could you justify that well if you find
a way to add more value you can earn
more and you can be abundant he figured
a way to get a 40 return for people in a
world where most people are putting
their money in a savings account getting
33 basis points one-third of one percent
if you got people one percent
opportunity be having 300 more value but
he's adding 12 000 more value for his
investors these people have taken their
money and they're able to do things for
their families for their businesses for
the causes they care about because he's
growing it at a multiplied level because
he developed this incredible set of
skills and how did he do it the way Jim
Rohn teaches he learned to work harder
on himself he learned to master skills
no one else had that could add value to
others so introducing you to Jim Rohn in
abundance I just want to Mark out that
you can earn 10 times more 20 times more
100 times more in the same amount of
time if you work harder in yourself than
anything else if you find a way to do
more for others than anyone else and
then it goes beyond money
then it goes to understanding abundance
as an emotion like love
like Joy it's the most amazing thing the
more of it that we give the more of it
we experience inside so learning to
create our minds the way we want is the
basis of creating the world the way we
want
that is a wonderful story in the yogic
lore
on a certain day a man took a walk
he went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate is indeed
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt a little
tired so he thought oh I'm tired I wish
I could rest somewhere
looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I'm well
rested
I wish I had something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
ask questions
food came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
your monkeys your tail fell away not me
Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey one
thing about a monkey is it's a necessary
moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is
if I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
all the ghosts have come they are going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization it in
turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is her simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
this things are completely removed by
this simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want the science that says there are
two minds that are operating at the same
time one is called the conscious mind or
one is called the subconscious mind I
say What's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I said what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you've experienced in your life and they
become habits so uh the subconscious
mind is not thinking creating a
subconscious mind push the button play
the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
I go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing
psychologists will tell us 70 percent or
more of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people in our mind
we start to realize that we're concerned
we're afraid we don't have enough I'm
not safe I'm not secure and I say oh
these thoughts I was talking about the
thoughts in your mind go in and control
your biology your genetics your
physiology and your health and I go yes
this is really true I said well how can
I tell you what your thoughts are in a
sense it can I read your thoughts and I
say yes you know I could put wires on
your head and it's called
electroencephalograph and I could read
your brain activity and I go oh great I
can see this brain activity
I want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head that
if I have a thought it's just for me not
for anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now I want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
Magneto encephalograph I say what's
unique about that I say read your brain
I say yeah but so does EEG I say yeah
but EEG put the wires on the head and
you get the electrical activity
conducted through the skin from the
brain and that's what I'm reading and I
said what's different about Meg
the probe is out here
and I said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head your thoughts are broadcast to the
field just like a radio broadcast I said
well what if I as an individual have a
thought that says let's have peace in
the world
and I broadcast out there in the street
and I say let's have peace and I look
around it's like where's the piece I
don't see the peace and here's what the
relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is Amplified each of us
has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field I say your Energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
I'll give you this most wonderful quote
I used it the other day in a lecture
from Albert Einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field so a definite definition the
field is the invisible energy right now
you're in a field there's cell phone
broadcast television television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field the
quote the field
is the soul governing agency of the
particle
particle is the material Realm
so what was Einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast the belief we change the world
I just want you to recognize as much as
I wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if I want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced that the war is
going to benefit them so that their
broadcasts say yes let's have a war
because I and my colleagues we're all
going to have a better result from that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga when you're in your postures
when you're in your process your mind is
sharing a thought not just in your head
but all around you so the whole idea
about this is we have to recognize we
are collectively creating reality with
our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking you get enough people to say
peace there will be peace instantly in
this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to give them the power to tell us
what we need
and as side Vegeta has been telling us
so importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and I really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field and
that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore what this world is looking
for at this moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 50
amazing rules from Louise Hay check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'm not talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear I'm talking
about just really respecting and
appreciating this incredible magnificent
being that we are